with the help of science humans are
capable of creating extraordinary things
too many papers is a series where I
explained the latest and greatest
research in a way that is understandable
and enjoyable to everyone we talk about
really exciting topics like machine
learning techniques to paint in the
style of famous artists life simulation
programs to create photorealistic images
on a computer fluid and smoke
simulations that are so high quality
that they are used in the movie industry
animating the movement of digital
creatures on a computer
building bridges with flying machines
and many more extremely exciting topics
research papers are for experts but two
minute papers is for everyone
creating each of these videos is a lot
of work I do almost everything on my own
researching these topics
audio recordings
audio engineering
and putting the videos together
and my wife Felicia designs these
beautiful thumbnails for each of them
and now you can become an active
supporter of two minute papers if you
help with only one dollar per month you
helped more than a few thousand
advertisement views on a video it's
insanity and it's tremendously helpful
and you also get really cool perks like
accessing upcoming episodes earlier or
deciding the topic of the next two
minute papers video 2 minute papers is
never going to be behind a paywall it
will always be free for everyone I feel
that it's just so honest I create videos
and if you like them you can say hey I
like what you're doing here's some help
that's really awesome if you'd like to
help just click on the patreon link at
the end of this video or in the
description box below or if you're
watching this on the patreon website
click become a patron and select an
amount and I am tremendously grateful
for your support also if you're already
a supporter of the show and feel that
you need this amount to make ends meet
no worries you can just cancel the
subscription at any time and if you
don't want to spend a dime or you can't
afford it it's completely okay I'm very
happy to have you around and please stay
with us and let's continue our journey
of science together let's show the world
how cool science and research really is
thanks for watching and I'm looking
forward to greeting you in our growing
club of fellow scholars Cheers